vladimir poutine a commencé cette guerre
il a créé cette crise alimentaire
mondiale et il est celui qui peut
l'arrêter
le conflit craignant concentre
l'attention du monde mais une autre
crise d'envergure aux menaces la corne
de l'afrique
alerte l'onu
330 millions de dollars manquent pour
faire face à la famine au nom du kenya
les éleveurs procédé des milliers de
vaches chèvres et moutons canton tous
les élans mots de ce village sont morts
à cause de la sécheresse seules cinq ou
six comme celui-ci ont survécu
pour cet éleveur la source de la plus
proche est à 15 km
les prochains à mourir c'est nous vous
comprenez
les effets de la famine sont déjà
visibles à l'hôpital où 77 enfants
sous-alimentés ont été amenés depuis le
1er janvier c'est deux fois plus que
l'année dernière
s'il ne pleut pas dans les prochaines
semaines 28 millions de personnes sont
menacées par une famine à grande échelle